well there was a movie called usual
suspects you ever see it I haven't yet
but that's why I've heard that name
before
it's a because I honestly it's I think
it's like Shawshank Redemption
okay you know my favorite movies it's
what Bryan Singer you know Bryan Singer
he yes that was you know Bryan's hair
not no no no I don't know him but his
name just makes me laugh cuz Brendan
Wardell did hit a joke in this old thing
and it was it's very funny yeah yeah
okay but Bryan Singer do you know he is
you probably hang with him in West
Hollywood no no no no no but Brendan
Brendan Wardell did you do where he
pleased to be a six year old kid and
he's like I got to go out cuz I heard
Bryan Singer's having that's personal
yeah but as a as a director is very good
as the director he's very fine personal
life yeah I don't I don't care about it
personally
but um he did a movie called usual
suspects and you had never seen Benicia
Latour before now he was in there okay
Kevin Spacey was in it you know and
probably shouldn't watch it them know
Gabriel Byrne it still I mean yeah maybe
you're right I don't know I think he
[ __ ] up the movie yeah
is that true like let me just say
something like if I'm on the road like
I'm in South Africa or whenever I'm in
my hotel room and The Cosby Show is on
yeah is it should not watch it reruns
gets in a car accident and then I'm
watching it is that bad I mean he is
getting residuals yeah really yeah like
okay fine Kelly song comes on yeah like
I have I have to louis c.k specials on
my I I tuned I mean on my yeah Todd
library and I
i watch him again is that that yeah you
gotta throw them out I can throw my
right so when when someone is in deep
deep and artist is in deep deep social
trouble right with that their their art
just goes out the window I don't know
people I think you know Michael well I
mean I think I think it just comes up to
you when you're by yourself you can do
whatever you want when you're by
yourself right
I don't know what porn you watch yeah
there's some weird porn yes like the
step the step porn is so big now what's
step one like step mom and stepson and
some daughter stepdad but it's not real
they're acting right yeah but still
yeah is the step gonna disappear and
it's just gonna be regular because it's
gonna happen soon because something
weird person is gonna do it and it's
gonna hit it's gonna hit the algorithm
and it's gonna go [ __ ] huge and
everyone's alright [ __ ] man we gotta
just make it I'm sorry to educate you
right now my friend but one of the most
classic pornos from the 80s
is it is taboo yeah which is daughter or
son there you go you know
father-daughter families the family
Shanna [ __ ] right now that they're doing
step right yeah still not it's not real
hey yeah yeah if it was real incest
though that's good happen probably gonna
happen on pornhub yeah yeah algorithm
hits man
[Music]